Hey,
what's going on is bill burn his time for
the Monday morning podcast for Monday?
Uh,
May 28th,
may 28 2018 what's going on?
How are,
Ooh,
oh, sorry. I just had to cry it out of me.
Well, the motorcycle. Oh, Jesus.
Ah,
if only kids knew how to
play basketball these days,
and I'm actually talking about
the Cavaliers and the Celtics.
If we just played basketball in the end,
if we just played basketball,
we actually could have, why didn't think
we'd win? Won Two games of that series.
I was just like the Barn James is
Lebron James. If we just fucking played,
but I didn't see one pick and roll that
whole fucking game. Maybe I missed it.
Mean I was having a couple as I
was sitting there just watching it.
It's game seven, you know, stressing out
ahead. I had to take the edge off the,
you know, I was talking to a
buddy of mine. I swear to God,
if you take a fucking three pointer
with nobody underneath and you miss that
should be in the stat sheet as a turnover.
That's all I'm going to say.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
This is what happens when everybody in
the league is a fucking one and done guy.
You know, they never took
a physics class or I dunno,
ever fucking had a ruler
and fucking measured.
Okay
Dude, we would, there was like six minutes
left. We're like down by, I don't know,
four, five, six, seven points.
We just start taking threes every
time we go down the court. Like,
like there was like five seconds left.
Like the crowd was counting down.
I don't know.
Having said that, I got to tell
you right now, Lebron James
in my mind,
Leapfrog Koby Bryant taking
that team to the NBA finals.
MMM.
I just, I just think Colby would have
been too far. He just didn't have the,
he just didn't have that thing.
He would just look at
everybody on the bench,
like the bumps they were and be like,
what the fuck?
And would just walk into the
front office and be like,
I'm not playing with this shit.
Get me better guys or I'm fucking leaving.
That's, that's how he got his title.
He was also a beast. You
know, I'm, I'm a Celtics fan,
so I always have to shit on him a
little bit. You know what I mean?
Yeah.
It's your me or shack. Um, the Black Mama,
he's ice cold. Except when he was
crying in the front office. Jesus belt.
Can you stay on topic? Sorry. This
has nothing to do with Bryan East.
One of the greatest players of
all fucking time. All right.
I'm just a fucking butt hurts Celtics
fan right now. Who's team way over a,
so I said I should be
happy. Um, but Lebron James,
what the fuck that guy
did? Jesus Christ. Um,
unbelievable. Speechless. I died. I
don't know. I don't know what to say.
And uh, from what I've heard, the
warriors are a little banged up.
They got that game seven tonight.
Uh, so I mean, I guess, you know, as,
as a fan of basketball
and more importantly,
competition,
I have to root for the Cavaliers
or the Houston Rockets. I mean,
do you just, you can't root for, uh,
a pile on team unless they're
playing another pile on team.
Isn't that how it works? And
admittedly, the Celtics had one in 2008.
Okay.
I didn't watch that team the whole year.
You know,
I watched during the playoffs
and we played the Lakers
and I was like, all right,
I'll pile on t verse your pile on team,
whatever. I'll do it. Um,
but I, congratulations.
Congratulations to the Cleveland
Cavaliers. Bron shapes.
Without a doubt. I mean, you gotta I
mean, I would put that guy like, I dunno,
it's hard. It's hard when you start
talking to Oscar Robertson, Bill Russell,
and I don't know where the fuck he is,
but he's passed Koby and the modern era.
I'd have to say that it's
him and Jordan and a,
I know a lot of your young kids right
now who didn't watch Michael Jordan. Uh,
you know,
you go back and you'd go into Youtube
when you watch his highlights and that
type of that guy,
he literally changed the game.
Um, I can't, I can't stress that enough.
Like the game changed. He didn't
dominate the game the way Colby did.
He literally changed it like, Oh, I
didn't know you could fucking do that.
I had no idea you could do that. My only
knock against the Bronch, James is what?
He fucking block that shot and then just
stood there, basking in his own amazing,
amazing amazingness or whatever.
And then the announcer Jackson goes every
once in a while I said something like,
every once in a while you make a play.
That's so unbelievable.
You have to stand there and admire it.
And I was sitting there like the
oldest old man ever go and like that,
that Yolo fucking, Yo, I
can't even believe how,
I can't even believe how amazing I am.
The fuck down the court,
you know,
you can't really say to help out your
teammates. He had a ball in his back,
but just what the fuck
was he doing back there?
Standing there for like 20 minutes like,
do you understand what
that dumb look on his face?
Like he just stopped a Scud missile.
You blocked his shot.
I Dunno, I am officially,
this is how old I am.
Okay.
This is how I was actually watching old
school TV shows and like I turn 50 next
as much as it's fucking with me,
I wouldn't change what I was born
to live now as a younger person.
And I'm for the simple
reason that when I was a kid,
this is what a theme song
sounded like on a TV show.
Sounds like a fucking porno.
All people playing that come on,
get to the fucking horns,
a nice big blue, white, whatever. You
knew somebody was getting fucked up
and those were all fucking people.
You know something after
they played that theme song,
they didn't stand in the studio admiring
and what the fuck they just did.
Other than that, I love Lebron James. I
do. I'm just breaking his fucking boss.
And I also love the city of Cleveland. And
I even still loved the city, Cleveland,
even after about five or
6,000 Cleveland Cavalier fans.
What APP?
Me sending me fucking all kinds
of shit over social media like,
like they weren't, they didn't have a
Cleveland steamer in their fucking pants.
Whatever the fuck. I hate
those stupid jokes, by the way.
You know what a dirty stage edges. No, I
doubt and yet keep the job to yourself.
It's all the same fucking egg.
When you stick your Dick in his shit
and you shove it up her nose and you go,
God bless you,
but you say it in Spanish.
It was water, bubbler, jokes.
Those are all jokes for people who
don't not to make a move. Right.
Did you stand there?
This one's cool.
Would you stick your dick
and you fucking polar comm?
Um Oh, that gives me do shells. I hate,
I always fucking hated those jokes.
Anyways.
Oh my God.
We used to trash Patrice when he
used to do those jokes on stage.
We still have Trisha doing street
jokes. You're doing street jokes. Um,
anyways, uh, I'm all over the
fucking map here. Sorry man.
I'm shaking off a game. Seven loss. Um,
I was just psyched that we got
to these two conference finals.
Then all of a sudden it's like,
Holy Shit,
we could actually win this fucking thing.
Then I'm like,
and if the warriors lose to the rocket,
so who gives a fuck about the rockets?
We always beat the rockets in the file.
We beat him in [inaudible] 81 and 86. Um,
we're going to have the TRIFECTA.
I, oh, Billy started dreaming
anyways,
so it was Cleveland Flint fans who
were talking all this crazy shit.
All right. Yeah. You're lying to
yourself if you forgot about that.
Jason Tatum Dunk on Lebron James.
Okay.
That right there is what's known
as the changing of the guard. Okay.
That was like the first time Shaq
having problems with his big toe.
Like that's the beginning of the end.
Okay.
And a new chapters coming
in and it's dressed in green
and white. All right. See,
but this one fucking guy,
I trashed them on Twitter.
He gave me some shit and he had
his stupid Cavaliers Jersey,
you know, and has had on, you know, with
this game seven look at his face. I said,
but he was wearing his seatbelt.
Okay.
I Dunno.
Some Cleveland plans when they look up
on the rafters and they start counting
banners, they forget that an
eastern conference championship
is not an NBA title.
Alright. And a division title
banner is, is literally,
that's like up. Like that's something you
give to a millennial. Like, all right,
you did something.
Um,
I don't know what else we got like
five people gave me shit. Why am,
why am I doing this right now? Why
am I being so childish? Oh God,
we were right fucking there. We
were right there. Um, anyways,
and I'm not gonna do that dumb shit of
like boom, cause so and so was there.
Your won fair and square. Everybody
gets heard. Lebron's heard, right?
You've probably all fucked up
carrying those people. Anyways,
congratulations.
That really didn't sound like a
congratulatory fucking 10 minutes here,
but that's, that's what I was trying to
get to. Congratulations to Cleveland.
All right. Even like eagles fans started
giving me shit. It's just like, dude,
are you fucking serious right now?
Good Lord.
And if Philadelphia, when did Philly
ever start talking shit about sports?
This is what I want all of you guys to do.
What is the championship combination
to open your city county championships?
Ours is five six eight 17 ah,
that unlocks to safe and all the rigs
pour out. What happens in Philly?
Philly is two, two, three one.
Okay,
go fuck yourselves. You fucking green.
Cons. You hang around long enough.
You're going to fucking win one.
That was another one.
This guy was giving me shit on the
Celtics won like 11 championships and four
there was anybody. It's like, all
right, well since then we won six.
Stop talking about the Cavaliers.
Like they were an expansion team.
They bet in the league
for almost 50 seasons.
Fucking Miami Heat showed up in 88.
I think they want more than the Celtics.
Well they went one did they
been for they want four.
Um, I dunno. Why am I
trashing cities? I don't,
I don't want to try. I don't give
a fuck about Philly. I like Philly.
I like Cleveland. I like all of this
shit. I'm just fucking, you know,
it still stinks that I lost.
I suck. I said, I wish,
I don't even fucking hate the
Yankees anymore. You can't hate them.
They're all basically they added one free
agent. Other than that, it's whole team.
It's just a,
I think I hate the Lakers to the
most just because I live out here,
you know?
I'd say that was, yeah, probably cause,
cause I live out here and then
Canadian fans, but they just, you know,
chasing their own fucking tails so they
don't even matter anymore. I don't know.
I guess not. I guess I'm just not
mad anymore. I mean, I'm still mad,
but I guess it probably is
childhood issues. Wow. Well,
why the fuck do I even watch sports?
All right guys.
I'm going to end this podcast and I just
had an epiphany. None of this matters.
Um, and he wasn't fucking with
you. God Damn it. Oh God. Oh,
what game seven state game. Seven
loss stinks. It really stinks.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Um,
I'm not gonna lie to you. I mean, I,
I haven't watched the, and so long.
I know I watched the Celtics like
all last season I watched him and uh,
I just,
I just cannot get over running down the
court and just fucking stopping and you
have to,
your teammates haven't even settled it.
Just pull it up and taken it three
and just now getting yanked out of the
fucking game.
The only thing that makes that okay
as the other teams are doing it too,
it's like watching this high
skilled like game at the YMC,
you know, there's no plays. Everybody
just met each other, you know,
you just fucking yacht. They're
trying to burn calories. Um,
alright bill, let it go. Okay,
I'll let it go. I'll let it go.
How bad ass is that fucking theme song?
It's from the streets of
San Francisco by the way.
I've been trying to find the original one,
but I went best I can find is the
Henry Man sees man Sini version of it.
That was the heyday
of the white cop chasing the
minority actor down the street.
And the only role that he was going
to get that decade, you know, um,
they should,
they should go back and they should do
a documentary on all those fucking guys,
you know,
like who has the record?
Like what black actor in the 70s had
the record for the most times he did a
scene where he was running down an alley,
being chased by the cops. You know,
when you get to the fence,
that's the scene I always wanted to do.
You get to the chain link
fence, you get like, you know,
a couple of rungs up and then they
grab you back. You're like, Nah,
they fucking drag you off
when you go and freckles.
Huh? You know, hurry is something.
Sorry man. I'm just not going nowhere.
Um, anyways, congratulations. And
other congratulations. I'm just,
I'm just being, this is me
in a very generous, thankful
mood. It's Memorial Day,
right? Thank in the troops, the people
that made the ultimate sacrifice,
you know,
it's a bit of a drop off to thank a
fucking professional basketball team after
you thank the troops. But, uh, you know,
congratulations to Daniel
Ricardo winning his first race,
a Formula One race in Monaco.
How about that?
That's the race I want to go to.
And it's probably the most
boring f one race cars.
That race is all about qualifying.
That's the race.
Whoever fucking wins DePaul position.
I mean,
they're racing in those little ass
fucking street. You know what I mean?
You know why those streets,
it's so small over there.
It's not because the city is so old
and used to just ride a horse down.
It's because that's a sovereign city
and that's the Illuminati money.
And they liked the bitches skinny.
They're like, I'm young and thin. Okay.
So that's,
that's their locked the door test.
If they can walk down the street without
the hips touching either building, uh,
then they'll have their
current wife, uh, disposed of.
I think that's what they do.
And then they stay young.
Evidently somebody sent me
this fucking thing in here.
I think this is how they stay young.
Somebody wrote to me said for
skin injections, the old bill,
what gives in Hollywood?
Uh,
my girlfriend show showed me a video
of an actress on Ellen talking about
injecting for skin cells.
Imported from Korea.
Korean circumcisions.
Sorry.
Into her face to look young.
Get out of their bill.
We can't have you injecting dick
skin into your face for roles.
The fuck's going on?
Um,
what do you mean what
the fuck is going on?
We are the leaders of how to
stay young out here in Hollywood.
Okay. What do you, what do you
think you'll Rogaine came from?
What do you think you're at? Your Grecian
formula is going to come from. Huh?
What do you think all your workouts
come from? They come from Hollywood.
All your fad diets. That's us. Okay.
We came up with all of that. You know why?
Cause you consider always trashing us.
You hold us to a higher standard.
Okay?
You look to us to see what
the future of vanity is.
You look to us to make it okay.
Okay.
Potok started out here. Now look
at, it's all over the country.
You're all fucking doing it. All
these real fucking housewives, Huh?
He all made fun of us and now look at you.
Oh he all on steroids.
You get in the fucking good hair plugs
because people out here in Hollywood,
you know had the decency to stick
those ant legs into their fucking heads
to let these doctors make mistakes with
their own face until it becomes safe
enough that you could sneak into some
fucking back alley and get the same
procedure done to you when you start
getting your man tits. All right sir.
How dare you make fun of Hollywood.
Thanks to our self involvement.
You'll be able to wear a tank top welling
to your sixties you're welcome sir.
I mean,
I dunno who's more fucking arrogant.
Cleveland Cavalier fans talking shit like
they own the NBA when all they ever do
is show up in the finals to
be the Washington generals.
Whoever the fuck they
sift that one you when they want.
Um
Huh.
Or you regular fucking people who sit
there and go on these fucking celebrities.
They need to be taken down a peg
and Yada Yada. Yad At fucking Yada.
Let me tell you something there.
Grill master you have to their foreman
grill or whatever type of fucking cookery
you have and your God damn kitchen.
Huh?
With your little fucking makeover
and you sad little fucking house,
you know?
And then you turn on the TV to see what
a dream looks like and who's standing
there?
Me and my bald fucking head.
Okay.
By the way, I'm not gonna lie to
you guys for my 50th birthday.
I think I'm going to give myself
hair plugs. I think I've earned them.
Okay. I'd like to brush
my teeth, you know,
and not stare at the sink.
Okay.
I would like to look up and see
something that I like and you know,
I just want to live my truth.
Okay.
You know, that's all that
I'm doing. And Hey, you know,
if hair plugs are going to make me
feel better than I say, I should do it.
And you know something,
I think it's time that I gave myself
permission to look sexy again.
Um,
why in the fuck would you ever
like,
I could see if she, if she had
American for skin cells. All right.
But like,
why would you get for skin cells imported
from a country that we're really not
getting along with? At least
not half of it. You know,
why don't you just get your botox from
China? It's probably where it's from.
Right? Said made from China, said um,
yeah,
people are out of their fucking minds.
MMM.
I am doing my damnedest to stay in shape,
but I am going to age fucking naturally.
That's it. You know what I mean?
Other than the I got a varicose
vein in my left leg, you know,
it looks like a God damn roadmap
to fucking Albuquerque. You know,
I might get that taken out at some point.
I keep meaning to get around to it,
but I never wear shorts, you know,
cause I respect people, you know,
all these fatties out there wearing
half shirts acting like they're brave.
You're not, you discussed it and
everybody should point at you.
Like we're in the invasion
of the body snatchers. Okay.
I don't care that you fat,
but you know, you put on put on a whole
shirt and maybe it is a whole shirt.
Maybe you just ate so much that now
we can see your belly again. You know,
like you ever see a woman with big tits
were and a half shirt and then when you
turn around to look at her it, it goes
all the way down to her ass in the back.
And it's like, oh, that's not a
half shirt. She just has giant tits.
She can't help it. She can't
help it. It's not her fault.
Um, anyways, uh,
I took my daughter, we went out
for a walk today and we went up,
we went on a hike and uh,
you know,
I was pushing the stroller the
whole way up. What a great workout.
And you go up the fucking hills
pushing a stroller, you know,
figure that's an extra 25 pounds
right there. Just pushing it away,
pushing it up the Goddamn Hill.
I saw this guy hiking with his daughter
and his son is, it got a little older.
I thought it was really cool. It was
like, man, I'd love to do that someday.
You know? Although his son was still
wearing his pajamas, I was just like,
come on man. You got to tell him, put his
clothes on. But then I was thinking like,
Dang, I leave my favorite pajamas and I
would've came to ah, right. All right.
All right son.
Now I wouldn't and I'd be like, all
right, well you wear them in the house.
Oh, whoa. Where am I? All right
then we're not going hiking.
Well, join the club, join the club.
Um, I, I really don't even know what
the Fuck I've been talking about it.
I'm just trying to fill up time here.
That's all I do here in this podcast.
If you new to it,
I'll tell you right now,
I've never been so offended in my life
that someone actually has the audacity to
make fun of the vanity of
Hollywood and the Boston Celtics
from two of the most simple combination
championship combination cities ever.
What is Cleveland? Cleveland
is zero. The Indians.
One in 48. I'll throw another one in
there. Let me, they, they'd fucking woman.
It's like, they're like zero one, two.
You know when it comes to championships,
I swear to God there should be a Fisher
price tag hanging off the ones in
Cleveland and saying your children,
when it comes to success out pill,
why would she go back into that bucket
or hate? Cause it's Gig. It's fine.
I must use the line from
bread. Darn. It keeps me warm.
All that heat is going to burn you up.
Keeps me warm.
Powers booth was it powers but
was power powers booth in that?
Um,
what a fucking name I powers booth.
You guys see Morgan Freeman
gotten a little bit of trouble
this week. I, you know,
nobody said how fucking cool it is than
an 80 year old guy could still fuck.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
why can't we look at the bright side
of sexual harassment in a plus? He's a,
he's 80. I mean what, what do you
think he's going to do? I mean,
you stop listening to music a couple of
years after high school. You get married,
you have a kid,
you don't know what the fuck's going on.
This guy doesn't know what's going on.
Wait,
what are you gonna do next to make
fun of the playlist on his flip phone?
He's in his fucking eighties
Oh my God.
I was so afraid.
I was so afraid when that guy
pushing a hundred that clip
where he was saying,
I wish I was there.
I thought he was making
fun of Michael Caine going,
I wish I was there when you stuck
your foot in your mouth saying,
are you pregnant? And the woman wasn't.
That's how I took it. I have no idea,
but what would I know?
What would I know about male
and female relationships? Okay,
what the fuck would I know? What was
I looking up again? Okay. CLEVELAND,
the Cleveland Indians.
This is such a country thing to do after
they just had success to talk about
their entire pastures,
but this is all I got.
This is what she listened to me is a sad,
pathetic man taking swings at people
who are no longer in the room.
They've moved on Cleveland Indians.
I want to, I want to coin that.
What is the, what is your, your your
combination what? Cleveland Indians.
World series [inaudible] chips and I put
it plural out of respect world series
titles too.
So they got two world series one NBA
zero Superbowls and we'll give them the
fucking Columbus blue jackets
with zero Stanley cups.
So the combination to
Cleveland is zero zero one two.
All right. Do you understand stand we've
one more super bowls. Then you have,
why am I doing this?
This is so checked because it's fun.
I'm not doing it to all Cleveland.
I'm just doing it to the fucking,
how do you only went to Superbowl?
I mean two world series and you
have like 58 retired numbers.
What'd you retire the numbers for?
For,
for having a fucking jumping
on the grenade and joining
that franchise. Oh, Bell.
I liked the Cleveland Indians.
You don't really as I kind of just had
a great weekend and I don't really have
anything to talk about. Uh Oh by the
way, did anybody see the highlight? I, I,
I, I don't know what I did. I tried
to favorite that thing on, on uh,
my Instagram page, which by
the way, I, I suck at it. Like,
I'm not making these stupid
videos go like, hey man,
I'm in the grocery store to
fucks up with cantaloupe.
Check me out at the San Jose Improv.
Okay.
Did you see that fucking Guy Moto GP race?
Where that fucking guy,
I can't even describe what a,
he basically he's stick,
they're all coming around the corner
were all two inches from each other.
One guy wipes out.
Okay.
Okay. And his bike lands
perpendicular to the guy behind him.
All right.
And the guy just hits the
gas and drives up over it.
Like a fucking stud man.
Yeah,
he's going a hundred and
something miles an hour.
He goes flying through the fucking air
and then lands on gravel and somehow
saves it. It doesn't go down and
continues on. Oh, and by the way,
like his airbag popped.
I don't know if you've ever seen
those guys when they get off.
The bikes were after they wipe
out their arms looking weird.
Like then like there were these weird,
you know when somebody gets knocked
out in their arms kind of go,
oh they kind of stick out. They
do that a little bit. And I, I'm,
I'm guessing that's because the airbag
popped and they can't bring their arms
back down. This guy's airbag popped,
making them less aerodynamic.
He continued to ride the race and
he's just fucking bad ass bad ass.
You know what I miss?
I miss the fucking Indy 500 after
interviewing Danica Patrick,
who by the way was so fucking bad ass.
And um,
I think it's really cool that
she's retiring, you know,
retire while you still have some
years left, you know, it doesn't look,
uh, you know, you don't want to limp out
of the league. Like fucking, you know,
Brett Farve, you know? Yeah. I don't
really think of those last few years,
but it's just like, dude, you're
in there, you're a hall of fame.
You one of the greatest
ever. What are you doing? Um,
you want to get out before then?
Um,
and then she also had like a vineyard
or something like that. It's really a,
that's the way to do it. That's the
way to get out of show Biz. You know,
I think the smothers brothers did that.
Okay.
Like didn't even announced their
retirement. They, from what I heard,
I was working in Vegas. They did
their last show at the Orleans casino.
Didn't say it was the last show.
Just said thank you.
Good night and just fucking
went retired to the vineyard.
How fucking bad. I mean
that is, that's that's it.
Like with Jordan hit
that last shot as a bowl.
Smothered brothers didn't come back
to play for the fucking wizards.
Um,
all right,
so Celtics lost a game seven and I
am in the last days of my forties.
I am basically sitting here with a
bottle of tampons in some Kleenex. This,
this is, this is the end of it,
man. You know, I mean, Jesus,
I look really good for fucking
50 I'm not going to lie to you,
but I'm going to tell you right
now, nobody looks good at 60. Okay.
I don't give a fuck what you do when
you're 60 you're 60 and all even I know
that's not true.
Kenny Aronoff did my podcast.
He looked fucking unbelievable
and he was a little north of 60.
All right, that's it. Katie.
Error on Kenny Aronoff Snell,
the guy I'm looking at.
All right.
The day that guy falls off,
whatever fucking year that
is going to be like, God man,
that's officially you fucking old.
Right?
There you go. Um, anyways, let me, let
me read a little bit of advertising here.
Fucking all over the God damn man. Oh,
look who it is. N. Dot. G. Dot. Oh, stig.
Stig looks great in his sixties.
Um,
talk about how a made to measure suit
fits compared to a generic off the rack
suit. Well, unless you the size
of a fucking mannequin. Yeah,
there's guns is going to be some problems.
Was that good end? Don't cheat out.
Is the world's largest made to measure
men's wear company and has been featured
in major publications including Gq,
Forbes,
and fast company,
Fast Company at about whores.
Guys love the wide selection of high
quality and the option to personalize all
details including your upheld your
lapel. All right, that's fucking cool.
Lining and monogram old school shit.
You get your initial split on the sleep.
Come on.
Here's how it works.
Visit a showroom or a shop online and
in@indochino.com pick your fabric,
choose your customization,
submit your measurements,
weight for your custom suit to arrive at
just a few weeks. Uh, you got to do that.
That's fucking cool.
This week my listeners can get any
premium Indochino suit for just 379
bucks@indochineo.com when entering burpee,
you are at checkout.
That's 50% off the regular price for a
made to fuck and measure premium suit
plus shipping is free.
That's indochino.com promo code birth
for any premium suit for just $379 and
free shipping.
Incredible deal for a suit that will fit
you better than anything off the wreck
ever could. All right, what do we got?
Oh my God. Dollar Shave Club, dude,
dude, you have a shower. Brush
your teeth to try to make your,
hey ya look presentable.
Hey, here's some good news.
Dollar Shave Club has a lot
of stuff to help you out.
The ugly bastard dollar shave,
ugly smelly bastard.
This is the copy. Should be.
Listen, dollar Shave Club
knows there's a lot of ugly,
smelly bastards out there
trying to get a piece of Pie.
You know you want to stop looking
so ugly and smell a little better.
Go to dollar shave club. Yes,
that's dollar shave club.
It delivers everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best. You name it.
Shampoo, conditioner, body wash,
toothpaste, Hair Gel, hair gel,
even a wipe that alleviate
tush feeling tingly, clean.
You'll be a big fan.
You know?
You know what those one wipe
Charlies are the cherry. Oh Cherry.
Those are the fucking, that's
the poor man's Butt Day. I
got to get some of those.
You know who doesn't want their ass?
Finland so fresh and so clean.
You'll be a big fan of their amber and
lavender common body cleanser after you
try it the first time when he had
drugging yourself. Fucking roofie.
Good luck finding a product
that great at the store.
All Dollar Shave club's products are
made with the top shelf ingredients,
ingredients that won't break your budget.
You'll feel the deputy,
they got grey goose vodka and this soap
plus shipping is included with your
membership.
I actually like Belvedere better.
And here's a great way to try a bunch
of dollar shave club products for just
five bucks. You can get their
daily essential style set.
Okay,
this is for men,
honey.
Have you seen my daily
essential starters that
it comes with body cleanser,
one wipe, they're amazing,
but wipes.
They're world famous shave
butter and their best razor.
This six blade executive,
uh,
keep the blades coming for a few
bucks more a month and add in shampoo,
toothpaste, or anything else you
need. Speaking of your next month,
for a limited time,
only use the code [inaudible] at checkout
to get $5 off your second month of the
club.
That's Code burr@dollarshaveclub.com
to save $5 on your second month.
Join the club today,
stamps.com lastly,
but not leastly the u s postal service
is an important tool for ready business.
Buy and print official US postage.
Ready Letter Eddie. Package Eddie,
class of bail using your
own computer and printer.
Okay.
stamps.com makes it easy like
that girl up the street too.
They'll send you a digital scale,
automatically calculates exact postage
stamps.com we'll even help you decide the
best class of mail based on needs.
No need to lease an expensive posted
from eater and there are no long term
commitments. Where is
this going? Nowhere lady.
I use stamps.com anytime I
send out my fucking posters,
I'm a moron if I could figure it out.
So can you,
okay.
Include your personal recommendation.
I just did absolutely no negative
references to the post office. Oh,
I love the post office and right now you
too can enjoy stamps.com servers with a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus postage and a digital scale.
Why can't I trash your competition?
The post office,
maybe this is the post
office's side piece. You know,
this is how they're going to gracefully
get out of the business. I don't know.
Was that negative? It wasn't
negative. It was just speculation.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com
and to
burn.
All right. Podcast is going to be a
little, little short this week. Everybody,
you know, it's going to be a,
just like that guy in taxi,
you know on, uh, what's it,
what is the fucking show there?
The fucking so always sunny in
Philadelphia. Spacing on the guy's name.
He was awesome in one. Flew
over the Cuckoo's nest. He
was in kindergarten cop. No,
he wasn't.
He was in twins.
Okay.
It was in romancing the stone,
I think.
Yeah.
Keep thinking Alan Alda.
Fuck he got drunk on a talk show
was hilarious. Louie Depalma.
Do you know what I'm talking
about? Anyways? Uh, all read
the force. Get injections,
the wine country advice.
A Billy Barolo breath.
Heard you talking to Danica Patrick
about why you said you were Nia.
Want to do a wine country trip?
Thought I'd give you some ideas.
I grow grapes and make wine for a small
producer in Sonoma county and I've been
in the wine industry for 10. All right.
You have established credibility,
why can't you just tell
me where the fuck to go?
Rather than reading me your entire resume,
you self-involved jackass.
How soon before this guy has fucking
Korean for skin cells injected into his
fucking gray teeth,
make his teeth white again
after all that Merlow um,
I am not drinking Marlo. I guess that
fucked up the whole Merlow industry.
I like Merlow. Um, first of all,
don't do Napa.
It's Douchey as fuck.
Uh,
honestly you only need to drive a couple
hours into Santa wine as valley for an
awesome weekend of wine tasting.
They have all kinds of great wines there,
but if you guys do want to come all the
way up to the quote real wine country,
I really do think Sonoma county
is better than nappy Napa County.
The mistake people make is going
to the actual town of Sonoma,
which is boring and pretty shitty.
Uh,
the move is to stay in Hell's dude,
you're hooking me up.
Helzberg which is in
northern Sonoma county. Shit.
Loads of excellent tasting rooms and
restaurants just walking around town plus
tons of other wineries nearby
to drive to slash hire a car.
Napa is only an hour away at most,
so you could always cruise
over there for a day.
If there are some specific Napa
wineries you want to check out,
it's okay if there's some specific
ones you want check out. But seriously,
Fuck Napa blown up way over price wide,
most of them,
which aren't great and they can't
even grow Pinot noire over there.
It's too hot and Pino is
the best wine there is.
Once you learn to notice and
appreciate the little details.
Bonus fact Les Claypool has a winery here.
He makes Pino because he knows what's up.
I fucking love Les Claypool
shape baby. Do you want to fucking drink
wine with me? Um, other football leagues.
Well thank you sir.
I'm going to fucking copy and paste that
and send it to my wife and see what she
says.
Or other football leagues.
Hey William Shit. Just
one. Oh, you know what?
I missed the Liverpool Cup final.
I'll have to catch their next
game next season. Evidently,
I don't even know who
won. I would think, uh,
Liverpool one a loss because I
didn't get any fucking, hey dude,
I hope you watched your adopted
team one Liverpool Cup final.
Uh, Geez against Madrid. Where
the fuck is it over here?
Why is my cable so slow?
Not Cable. My Internet.
Okay,
come on. You fuck hoes? Come on. Come on.
Why? Well, I don't fucking know.
Oh, you don't? Never, definitely.
My computer is allergic to soccer.
Uh,
okay.
Other football leagues.
Hey William shivers was wondering since
Johnny Manzel has made the switch,
if you ever watch any CFL,
I love the CFL.
CFL is so fucking underrated.
CFL is better than college football.
That's a bunch of college all starts
that weren't quite good enough to make it
to the NFL. But what? Hawaii,
any college football team,
bigger field. It's exciting. I don't
even know what the fuck's going on.
And there's only like six tapes,
right?
The Edmonton Eskimos. They're like
your Washington Redskins, right?
Are they getting pressured to change
that name? The Calgary rough riders,
the BCA Eagles on as the Calgary
stampede, right? Isn't it
the Winnipeg nostril stickers
or something like that?
Something about the cold weather out
there. I don't fucking know. Um, oh,
by the way, tonight's the first
night of the Stanley Cup finals,
right? Stanley Cup final, not the
NBA finals. Stanley Cup final.
And congratulations to the fucking Vegas
nights and the Washington capitals.
That's going to be exciting
to see the team win. But uh,
I'm really pulling for the capitals.
I'm a big,
I'm a big fan of a fucking, what's
his face say? Oh, a vet chicken.
You know, Russian players get
a bad name in the NHL. Uh,
cause I guess a number of them could
give a fuck about winning a Stanley Cup.
You know, who is that guy, that sign,
you know, it was fucking amazing.
Played for the Atlanta thrashers.
Got a giant contract with New Jersey
was just like, yeah, you know,
I just don't give a fuck. And he
left, went back to play hockey and uh,
Russia like the Stanley Cup does,
like that's the stereotype that it doesn't
mean shit to these guys. All right.
So guys like you know, Mulkin in
Ovechkin got a bear. The, the,
the carry a load of these other Russian
constant I guess didn't give a shit.
So I'm rooting for that guy.
You know,
Trump probably wouldn't like
it then I'm rooting for Russia,
but I want to see him. Uh, I
want to see him win one. Um,
we should, we shall see. But what's
his face? Uh, Vince Neil Motley Crue,
one of my favorite groups of all time.
He's out in Vegas and he's become
a big fucking Vegas Knights Fan.
So no matter what, I'm going to be
happy whoever wins. Um, anyways,
other football leaks,
uh,
I would absolutely watch the CFL. The
biggest differences. Our field is longer,
long and wider with bigger end zones in
field goal posts are on the goal line.
Uh,
we also function on a three down system.
I'm probably a poor source for the rules,
but hey,
I'm just some jackass right
into the podcast. Well, let
me know when it starts. Ps,
you should see a Saskatchewan
rough riders game.
We are considered one of the best
football fan bases around and do a show in
Saskatoon too. While you're at it, go fuck
yourself and have a lovely day. I did.
I did a show. That's how
I know you guys go. Ooh.
I did a show in Saskatoon,
Saskatchewan.
I did one in Saskatoon and Regina
that steady, that rhymes with fun.
I never need to hear that again.
Um, I'll definitely be back.
It's fucking God's country up there.
And you can see the northern
lights like all year round.
A boyfriend found out I cheated
on my ex husband. Oh boy.
Uh, Billy Babushka Lips. What the
fuck is Babushka I gotta look that up.
MMM.
Liverpool quest for glory ends in tears.
Is Gareth Bale wonder goal breaks heart.
Oh No. Oh, I had enough sports
pain for the fucking weekend.
What happened?
Okay,
I'm clicking on the link.
Why won't you do anything?
Alright,
what was I looking at?
Babushka
it's one of my favorite words of all time.
I don't even know what it means.
Oh, Billy Babushka. That
was a wrestling manager.
That would be my name. Alright.
Should I end my relationship,
my boyfriend of a year and a half fun out.
I cheated on my ex husband.
He's not being a huge dick about it.
Just passive aggressive whenever shit
goes down, which is not too often.
He's a little bit,
he's a little on the sensitive side,
but until he found out about my past,
that's what I liked about him.
He's a math computer guy, not an
Alpha male. Uh, well, you know,
if you get what you pay for sweetheart,
he does not care what people think about
him and he has a unique sense of humor.
His family definitely has mental issues.
His Dad refused to stay on dialysis and
died when he was in high school and two
older brothers off themselves when he
was a sophomore and a senior in college.
Jesus fucking Christ Dayton,
the Hemingways here.
I'm in my mid thirties
and have a good job.
He's two years older and has a great job,
owns a house in a good neighborhood.
No kids involved. Our relationship
is the best I've ever had.
I feel a lot of love recently though,
after he found out I sense a lapse.
He never wants to talk about it. I could
never imagine myself cheating again.
I got married to my ex too young,
but now that my baby making years are
coming to an end, I don't know what to do.
Should I stick around to see if we
get back to where we were or move on?
Go drink yourself.
Um,
okay.
Yeah, I don't fuck it. I,
you know, I don't know.
I don't know.
Um,
just be like, look, I
you ever going to be able to get,
just ask him,
are you going to be able to get past this?
You know, here's the thing. You know,
you did do it so
it gives you shit.
I kind of got to roll with it.
I guess I have gives a fuck.
Yeah.
I just rolled with it for a little bit
and just see a full fucking sensitive,
sensitive are there. Um, I know
people always say that, you know,
if you fucking cheat, you're going
to cheat again. I, and I don't know.
It all depends on where you are in
your life. Who the fuck you're with?
I don't know about that one. Has there
been a study on that? I have no idea.
I honestly don't know
what to tell you man. Um,
maybe you could turn it into some sort
of math joke. Uh, dating older women.
Dear Billy blue balls.
My name is prince.
I am 23 and about to
be 24 in about a month.
I am in a relationship with a 44
year old woman. Yeah, this is easy.
Get the fuck out of it.
You're not in a relationship.
You're banging a 44 year old woman.
Uh,
now I know what you are thinking.
Mommy issues much now.
And I don't end fucking sentences
with the word much. Nonetheless.
I just said, hey, that's too much.
I don't know. There's some fucking,
I hate that. Something something much.
You know what else they, when I hate, uh,
so and so, and then at something in
quotes me something in quotes in the year.
Always the coolest
fucking person. Ah, Bill,
you're all get over it. People
talk differently now. All right?
We remember when you were young
and everybody would yell, not,
you didn't think that was annoying
to older people. All right,
you got me now I know what
you are thinking. Okay,
now I know what you're thinking.
Mommy issues much yet.
That is part of the reason I am with her,
if I'm being honest. Well, there you go.
Gotta love honesty.
We have been dating for about five
months now and things are good,
but there are things that
irritate the hell out of me.
What her fucking silver pubic hair.
Uh,
like she thinks some of my views on
life and other things that are odd.
I honestly think it's because she grew
up in a totally different times. Yeah.
It's called a generation gap.
If he gets your face out of her gap and
look at the fucking calendar. Sorry.
Um, we had been dating for about
five months now and things are good.
No they're not. But there are things
that irritate. Okay, I read this.
They're not good, sir. You need
to get the fuck out of this.
This is not going to end well. Some
point you're going to want to have a kid,
all right. And her vagina is
going to be in a fucking museum.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
with the fuck wasn't something that's
definitely different time than me,
but some of it is that
she isn't into science
or she better be if going
to try to keep herself
young.
Like we got into an argument about high
fructose corn syrup because she said
it's only sugar until I prove to her
that it's not just sugar and she thinks
that's not really science.
Okay.
Yeah.
I thought you were into science.
You're just reading facts that scientists
figured out that's not science.
Right? I mean, I could, I mean the fact
that I could look that up and just go,
here it is. That's not scientist. If I
can figure it out, it's not science, sir.
Um, and she thinks my fear of
chemicals in our food is odd as well.
It's hard being with someone that doesn't
get me another thing in another thing
in a black male. Oh, I'm a black
male and she's a white female,
so she doesn't really understand how
it is to be a black man in this day.
And that Jesus fucking Christ, sir.
How many red flags do you need?
Okay.
You know, and, and she's, uh,
she got fired from the Police
Department for dropping the n word.
Other than that, I think I really liked
her. Sarah, what the fuck are you doing?
I'm going to keep going here and did
jump taught, uh, and did jump topic. Uh,
sex with her is good,
but it's like we only have
sex once and it sucks.
She says it's because I leave
or to, so a, okay. I'm not,
I leave her to soar as you know.
Is there anything worse than a big
fucking Dick? Nincompoop I can't fuck it.
I know at 1:00 AM 1:00 AM I
supposed to do with you, sir?
You and your porno cock need
to fucking date somebody,
uh, you know, from, from,
she's almost twice your age.
Okay.
And she listens to country.
But this is such a fucked up email.
I don't believe it.
I'm calling bullshit on that one.
Yeah,
you kind of did a slow roll on me.
You had me, you had me, you had me,
and then you sat and I'm black
and I got a big deck ad she saw.
I don't believe it.
Okay.
Maybe it's true.
He goes,
I want to have excitement and shit in
our relationship and she just doesn't
bring that to the table. I like her a lot
and we watched documentaries together.
I'm sure. Did she fall asleep
half way through it like I do.
Um, anyways. All right.
Okay.
Okay. And she has a venereal
disease, but you know,
other than that, you
know, we laugh a lot. Ah,
fuck. All right. Do we
have anything else here?
Is there anything else that that needs
to be discussed other than why is my
computer that I got kicked off line.
Okay.
You know,
and now novel,
it'd be funny if I never
go to the Internet again in
the last thing I did was I
looked up Babushka
um,
all right. People. It's
Memorial Day. Whose kid? No,
you're not fucking working today either.
All right.
I have to go to a picnic. That kid
picnic and I can't wait. You know what?
I actually got a great book here.
It says 88 great daddy daughter dates.
I think I'm going to do most of these.
You know, I got all these books. You know,
uh, dad's prayer for his daughter's
daughter. That's fucking weird.
Strong fathers, strong
daughters. 10 secrets every
father should know. All right,
let's read a little bit of
this sandwich to the salary.
Protect her defender. Okay. She needs,
oh my God. This is like, all right.
How dumb would you have to be to
read this fucking book? Okay. One,
you are the most important
man in her life. Chapter two,
she needs a hero.
Chapter three,
you are her first love chapter
four, teacher humility. Oh,
she shouldn't stand there like Lebron
James after he just blocked a shot a her
defender and use a shotgun if necessary.
Pragmatism and grit.
Your two greatest,
I'll read that chapter because I don't
know what either one of those meets.
I know one of them was a John Wayne movie.
Be the man you want her
to marry. Gross. Uh,
teacher of who God is. Gross
teacher to fight. That's right.
There you go.
Keep her connected
afterward. Acknowledgments, bibliography,
notes, index. I don't know what those
last thing chapters were about. Let's see.
Let's read the chapter.
Start with index here.
Let's see what the Hell I'm supposed
to tell my daughter a abortion.
12 abstinence comma went 13 dash one 14.
Uh, this doesn't make any
sense. Add health study,
Adhd,
advertising. African Americans.
This book is all over the place.
African Americans and it
says depression and st
ds aids.
But why did you have to
drag black people into this?
Alcohol use is a weird chapter. I don't
think I liked this book. I know that.
I don't know who wrote. Um, anyways.
Oh, fucking Billy burger face is
going to go fucking turn on the grill.
Make a few here. Um, it's just one of
my last podcast in my 40. [inaudible]
this is so stupid. I'm turning 50. I'm
not going to feel any fucking differently.
Um,
I'm definitely gonna try to eat better
and I've been doing that for the last
three months,
and I was facetiming with somebody and
they would like to have you lost weight.
And I was like, Nah, not
really. I was excited.
Um, so anyways, um,
I think that's it, right? Anything I'm
doing a Trump do my double bass drum.
It's coming along. It's coming along,
you know, working on that song.
I had the beholder eye of the
beholder. Little Metallica. Oh.
And I played streets of San Francisco.
It's all serendipity. All right. This is,
this is it.
I'm done.
I'm not going to just fucking me and her
for another fucking six minutes just to
say I did it. Uh, once again, I apologize.
Everybody in Cleveland and in
Philly for being a content, right.
You want a Superbowl?
Congratulations. She'd go in
the NBA finals. Congratulations.
I hope you fucking cheese steaks and a,
whenever the fuck it is.
You guys eat there in Cleveland.
I hope they taste extra better today.
Extra special. All right, I'm
off to watch some baseball.